bro this guy's got a question about
something i think you guys have both
been watching can i talk about kingdom
first yes
yeah okay let's listen to this guy
okay play the guy
big tiger valley fan here um i'm
crossing the tracks
you've seen the new reboot karate kid
reboot
what you think of it and if you would
make a guest appearance
as mr miyagi game
thank you for your question brother i
appreciate that man i appreciate you
being obviously this guy i'm going to go
out on a limb
and say this guy is filipino
or athletic and relaxed
dominican
[Laughter]
and he wants to know if you'd be mr
miyagi and the wildest thing is bobby i
thought about that a minute ago i said i
wonder if bobby's been approached
about being uh going yagi going full
yagi
it's funny first of all
people do this all the time they go god
he looks like him doesn't he sorry
go on
[Music]
first of all people do this all the time
when they go um they say stuff like
why why weren't you in that you should
you why didn't you do that
yeah right and you go like some movie
comes out
like crazy ridge asians people go hey
why didn't you do that
they didn't ask me
right yeah i want to be in it yeah
people like get mad at me yeah why don't
you do that you should have done that
and go i did want to do it yeah they
don't want me in it
you know or like people go like that
you should be karate kid miyagi yeah
first of all he was like
70 years old when he did it he was 51.
was he really yeah i could do
i'll do it i'll do it i'll do it you
would be too goofy man
why no ah you guys very much look very
similar
and r.i.p him he died yeah
he died from um smoking huh
well i i heard different stories that he
was an alcoholic
yeah yeah i you know i i have a and
that's back when it was heavy but
there's a funny story about him um he
used to go to hawaii all the time
right because he was friends with you
know who don ho is yeah this is the
musician
yeah pep morita so he used to go to don
josh shows all the time
but he used to go there to do one joke
right and so donahoe
would if donahoe knew a pat morita was
in the audience
downhill would stop like in the middle
of the show and goes ladies and
gentlemen tiny bubbles to you
you know what i mean and people go yay
right and he goes my friend is here in
the audience you know
he's a good friend of mine he's a
celebrity he's one of my best friends in
the world
uh pet marita please they should have
they shut
um a light on them cat marina and
and donald would go stand up pamerito
and pamerito's joke would be a
i am standing and everyone would laugh
and he would only go to do that one joke
and then you just get plastered and get
blown by hawaiian women oh god you gotta
love that
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video
you just saw i mean it was okay but
the next video you can watch could be
way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch
watches one
ah